everyone who starts CrossFit can just do
regular CrossFit for six months or maybe
two years and continually get better
your body is has been exposed to
CrossFit knows what it's about and then
and you also know what it is and then
start looking into maybe fine-tune areas
but yeah anyone that's looking to
compete at any level if you've got to a
point where your lifts have stared at a
certain level you don't feel like
getting much fitter gymnastics isn't get
much better and you're doing all those
things in like it's all muddled up in
that one section and it's time to stop
separate them work on them individually
work on your weightlifting work on you
you're conditioned working in gymnastics
build them all up separately and then
bring them back together
Steve Fossett in the building how are
you man good thank you thanks for having
me on well thanks for traveling to Wigan
to be beautiful look at this in there in
the dungeon I know this is my little man
cave it's cool man it's very cool he's
come back from Miami yes I was a yeah
such a good tan such a good time I've
been back for a a week or so now but in
terms of competitions probably the most
fun that I've ever had why probably a
couple of things mixture of who who I
was with who moves around there was a I
was there competing in a team with
Taylor Anita and Mikey but we also had a
little bit of a jest he crew going on
with Reggie and Phillip the dance like a
Phillip discard and the girls as well so
as Evie and I loved that it was a good
group of maybe a torn animals yeah we've
all known each other quite a while so
it's good just to go out to Miami which
is some ways completely different yeah
Wigan Oh slightly different oh wait give
me a look and just go and have a good
time and you know it's like being around
Mackay and Reggie they just bounce off
each other and you know there's kind of
laser sharp focus when it's time for the
event and the warming up and then 10-15
minutes after it's just back to just
having a good time so it's something
that have not always had that balance of
around competition sometimes I get
myself kind of in the zone and the full
aspect is maybe just kind of like
limited because I'm so focused on I
wanted to compete and so having those
guys there was I just made it yeah
really very wonderful experience do you
think that you can have the level of
focus that you want from yourself and
from your athletes whilst still having
that turn off it's yeah is it a very
hard balance if I was there if we were
there competing and we were going there
knowing full well that we were going to
be a top 3 team and via any games ticket
than me whoever or not the environment
would have changed just kind of
naturally like people would have been a
bit more serious I'm not sure but I mean
I'm sure there is a balance out there
but it's a thing it's a very hard
balance for people to find because
I mean if there's three hours between
events and this next event is
potentially going to be life-changing
with the result that comes then it's
quite hard to be you know it's quite
hard to be acting the way that we were
acting last week so I'm sure some people
have the balance but I think everyone's
balance is just a little bit different
we watch it right you can see different
personalities come across within the
games you know watching the
documentaries and stuff like that you
see some people they were kind of
especially some of the girls some of
them seem to have real polarized laser
focus yeah and others seem to be kind of
like giggly spending time with partner
or their coach and like laughs and just
doing girl stuff you know I mean yeah
yeah definitely and like I say I think
everyone has that balance it's a bit
it's different I've got a 10 maybe 11
individual athletes and every single one
of them has a different balance some
like speech you know talking to people
in between events going into the crowd
and walking around the vendor village
and just kind of mixing other people and
other people just like to go like full
hermit mode and just show off from the
world so yeah I mean it's what's right
and wrong there's probably no particular
way I guess it's just it's down to each
you sell to each person can switch a
flea are there any rules that you think
all athletes should try and adhere to
with in competition periods like for
news sleep nutrition anything like that
yeah I think yeah I think sleep is
definitely something that just it's not
it doesn't differ that much with
different athletes
everyone needs as much sleep as they can
especially on competition we can mix
quite hard to get a full night's sleep
because of no percentage and I was gonna
say I've never been in so you've been
even the games you've been what Apple is
you've been to a number of big big comps
yeah
what is your sleep like in between those
cuz you know you're so exhausted from
the day but also so terrified for
tomorrow yeah personally I never have
struggled to fall asleep
it's the waking up I would prompt I
would wake up a couple of hours earlier
than usual
something like four or five o'clock
because you know sometimes if you you do
wake up my scene go for a week toyline
and then you start thinking games yeah
there's only five miles into the floor
in front of area in front of everyone
and that's kind of when like that you
see an s kind of wakes up properly cuz
it's kind of going into that fight mode
and then itch it's softer get back to
sleep so I probably probably drop sleep
by two or three hours as the Lion stage
in the morning but it's just important
that the weeks before that is when you
can control it and you can get a good
sleep that you kind of get that sleep in
the bank
so yeah sleeps definitely something that
they'd all need and like I said
nutrition is probably a different thing
I'm not I've got people helping me with
nutrition to help my athletes with
nutrition because it's quite a big bra
thing there's programming of cautions
and nutrition it's a lot for kind of one
person to try and control everything
some people deal well with a lot of food
during the events some people deal well
with barely any what's your disposition
I like to eat some food as as soon as
possible and it's probably something
that I can I've got myself into the
habit of back in the early days of
competing it was just like a shake and
some smoothie and then get by but then
by the end of the weekend it was it
would always take its toll fact that is
just no kind of like solid food in there
to feel me but now you don't have to
working with some some some guys for the
last few years I need to get food or
what's your favorites intra event snap
or food it's really boring to be honest
is really lurid just sweet potatoes and
some white meat white fish obviously
you've got you can be drinks and stuff
like that but I think I drank a bit as
bland as possible yes you know you don't
want to be out of breath and a lot of
the middle oh yeah sauce going up or
there's something horrible
coming up some fishy and some fishy
burps so yeah it's really uh it's really
not - okay
excited just what I said so you're
spending this weekend at water Palooza
we're the team of guys who there's some
young ones and some people that have got
experience similar to yourself in there
as well are you giving them coaching
with regards to their mindset during
that time what guys we need to think
about this what about you know speaking
of the girlfriends or the partners or
their phones or you know what you're
doing on that side yeah so a lot of this
season and and with having what a ploy
to just gone a lot of my focus towards
the athletes is just trying to relay as
much knowledge and education to them
around competition and training while
whilst doing it with them there's one
thing like trying to teach them as a
coach and then there's another thing
being by the side as an athlete saying
you should be doing this that on the
other owner and I find that being in the
team with a bunch of guys or being there
at the competition and maybe even
competing in training with them athletes
tend to pick up a lot they'll pick up a
lot more than just like having that
coach athlete relationship where coach
says this athlete does anything for
example as well as acting in there and
then showing them Mike why things help
and that's why recently over the last
few months I've enjoyed getting back
into training and competing because
we've got a lot of younger athletes
coming up through the ranks and I find
that the results that we've had from
Jesse over the last kind of a us over
years I've come off the back of that
where I've been in the kind of
environment of competing and training as
well as coaching at the same time rather
than just being kind of step back and
saying well I'm coach now do this like I
find that getting that environment and
that group of people together and and
putting the knowledge and education into
moving that way
it's helping the guys develop much
better it's interesting to see people
that lead by example especially in a
spot like CrossFit right every
crossfitter respect hard work yeah
it's very much a nose grindstone
suffering sport yeah and
I wonder I wonder how much extra a coach
brings by leading by example versus how
much they lose by having to inevitably
sacrifice a tiny bit of coaching
performance to focus on their own
performance yeah you know I mean like
there's a visit there's a real balance
there but I would say certainly knowing
Reggie Mikey Taylor seen us some of the
guys that you work with yeah they're the
sort of team I think that would toward
wanting to see you live the lessons
you're trying to give to them yeah 100%
and look like I'm living that example
right now is last year I thought more of
a step away and went more coaching role
GOx wife Coach Taylor and Jack Cochise
Mike and Reggie and we very much had
lucky and the coach set away and then
there the athlete and more recently
we've got more involved and with
training with them and competing with
them and they're coming on much quicker
and you can tell they enjoy the fact
that the coach is in there with them
rather than just being kind of stood
there telling them to do this right in
this in the program if were in there get
involved and doing it with them and then
able to also teach them and I say
educate them on just the small or minut
details because they seals doing them
and then they ask oh why are you doing
that for why not wearing trainers what
why wearing left and choose or why not
wearing a belt all this really small
minut details were when you were in that
coach kind of away from them it might
you know you might not pick up all the
small at all especially coming out there
as a competitor first or a competitor
coach like running in parallel yeah
that's definitely a unique selling point
there's far more coaches and athletes
than there are coach and athlete Yeah
right yeah 100% understand let's be
honest I just went through because
that's how I learnt as an athlete I
learns as an athlete when I was around
all their athletes are all the coaches
that were kind of involved and more
more practically involved than just kind
of a standoff I can't do as I say so and
just kind of took that same kind of
method up in sport that I felt I learned
them often and just passed now any stuff
that you've picked up since over the
last couple of years since the games
since what a polluter and stuff that
you've brought into comp weekends that
you've thought was a bit of a
realization what yeah what's it been
yeah in what an essence anything ma'am
so if have you realized that having an
that between competitions is a good idea
if you realize that you need to leave
you farm down if you realize that you
need to spend time warming up more time
last time whatever yeah I mean yeah if
it comes down to it there's a lot
there's a lot of different things you
when that could work it couldn't work
like phones on or off and again it
sounds like I said Matt answer it comes
down a lot comes down to the individual
if some people actually need that little
bit of time on the phone just escape and
other people are getting too involved
that's gonna start in fact effect in the
performance I think ultimately it's it's
making sure that whatever whatever is
the doing it's keeping them in the right
mind frame the right positive mind frame
to always approach that next event you
know with the right mindset that that
they need to know you need to know your
athlete very well yeah for that to
ethics like I said the 10 the 10
athletes I've got my attitude towards
each one of them is different it's just
two examples for if David shrunk and and
Taylor how when David walks into the
warp area is what his earphones on and
then recall his gory face I don't if you
heard the nerve Ram some home and
sometimes I'm scared talking to him
because he's just looks like
laser-focused from when he when he
decides that warm started if phones go
in and it means business from that point
and there's not really much joking
around
from that point it's just it wants to
get perfect warm-up
make sure he's feeling like 100 percent
as soon as you step
that competition for everything is very
kind of serious and just kind of
fine-tune business mine yeah like it
that's that's when I start comes off the
comes off the arena floor smells clean
up at the time and and and he's it's
back to being his usual self
whereas Taylor just kind of needs a
little bit more bit more like tatted you
just the odd job in war like it'll keep
her kind of smile and keep her happy and
that makes her perform better so it is
like it's like it's the balance of the
different athletes and it's
understanding what makes people tick we
have too much for servicing and what's 9
off your one athlete who needs to get
into their head more and one athlete
that probably needs to get out of their
head more yeah so this is one of the
things I think is interesting about you
know everyone that's listening that does
CrossFit they want the secret sauce
right they want like yeah but what no no
no I know that you saying like it's
individual and stuff but yeah like huh
how much sleep do I need or yeah how
long do I need to warm up or whatever
and the fact that we all are very unique
individuals unfortunately makes these
prescriptive like rules for people to
follow and I suppose this is the value
of a coach yeah right yeah yeah a
hundred percent and and uh the whole
thing is what we try and get it across
to all the guys that are on our programs
no matter what tier they're on the could
be on the 40-pound program where we've
got hundreds of people following all
that all the way up to each one to one
individual and it's just the tools to be
able to know what to educate them so
that they can make their own decisions
for lost the best for them and if if
every athlete you can then make the
wrong decision you know and and they
know that's the right decision for them
whether it's what to e after a comp how
much sleep they should get should they
have a nap in between hydration you know
where in certain equipment on some
events and not the others if they know
and they're educated and they can make
that decision himself then it's gonna be
far more effective than a coach trying
to guess what Rack them think everyone
knows himself better than anyone else
knows them
so education for the athletes is key and
I something that we try really hard to
get across with the guys on the program
so that they can make the right
decisions because someone's not there's
not always gonna be someone there that
can tell you what to do you need to be
able to if it's middle under there then
or interest you and you judge on that on
the competition floor like something
happens you need to be able to make a
decision yourself based off your own
knowledge it's a great point you can't
rely on your coaches some crud out every
exactly incident that occurs so you've
touched on it there the fact that jst
over the last few years has seen quite a
bit of success mm-hmm
what are some of the accolades that you
guys have yeah so we've got so we were
the first so I was the first British
male its qualifier games so it's British
male really yeah out of regionals there
is that there was actually a guy and
Jamie it's called maybe 2009 qualify
through us I think called a sectionals
Butland bout of regionals the first
British guy and then in week 2 years
later we were the first British team to
the games and then two years later tour
last year 2019 we made it back again as
they're well a second on the bridge team
and to get there and we were the team of
six so individual team of six teams team
or four where the years rest in between
yeah yeah yeah pretty much yeah 12 15 17
19 nice so yeah you've seen some real
you know that that's a number of
different experience yeah and and on top
of that like firsts right so yeah what
is it about jst x' approach to coaching
or programming or training yeah what's
moving the needle here do you know I
think it's doing a lot of little things
the right way and this is something that
I only come in to terms with now kind of
like they're older I'm getting them more
more people more athletes I see and my
gyms I'm getting about it I'm seeing
people just doing the little things not
not optimally not that not the right way
and is and it
a lot of really small little things but
like I'm like why are you wearing laughs
ever talks about why wearing trainers
2ds that's what's instead of lifting
shoes at this point in the season so
just to explain that one itself they're
lifting shoes are gonna help most people
lift they're going to help most people
squat better saying most not everyone
balls they're making you better at
lifting because it's an an accessory
that's going on - it's not yourself it's
something they're adding to your body so
learning to squats or lift without that
added performer we call that performing
performance enhancing accessory happy
learning to lift without them and then
introducing them closer to competition
so it does give you that effect he's
going to put you at a higher level than
if you just wore them all year round
because you're improving your own body's
ability to do whatever it is you're
trying to do and then you're adding on
the the performance enhancing no
accessory and there's just like that one
small tiny little thing another main
thing is maybe resetting on you your
snaps deadlifts instead of touching if
it's three sets of three snatch deadlift
so many people I will see just do
touching go it's like again it's a very
small thing but you do know snatch
deadlift a three sets of three a high
percentage so it transfers into one rep
max snatch so doing that touching go a
rep is not about a second rep in the
third rep it's not transferring into a 1
into your one rep where you pulling it
from a dead stop off the floor and like
I say loads of really small tiny things
and this is what I'm having a lot of fun
doing now is educating the likes of
Taylor David and vacuum and Reggie with
Jack to get all the really small details
of how to live the life and how to
approach a training session how to
recover from a training session you know
when to when to supplement went to time
certain meals I've got all these fine
little little details and we call them
inches
all of them all of them done the right
way or say if all of them the right way
over one week is ten things that you've
leave 10 inches that done for six months
is just then it starts to snowball yeah
and yeah exactly yards and and miles but
that that's something that I only really
now have realized that we've started
doing and we just have to do from from
the beginning
so we're stuff that I had learned I mean
passed down from other cultures nor
athletes I'd I had competed and worked
with and then we kind of had this group
in the beginning at jst we had this
group of maybe 10 or so athletes where
we'd would would always be training
together if someone was doing something
wrong if someone were and lifting shoes
when it didn't really make sense for
them as well as issues they'd be told in
a nice way and said lotty should not
wear them because they stay on the other
belts would only be used at a certain
stage and and then coaching cues and
techniques you know little things that
just get tweets but going round and
round in that those 10 people for weeks
months and years on end made those 10
people get to a high level and then
that's that kind of snowballed again
though people wanted to get involved and
and the whole knowledge and education of
just kind of training living and the
what having the professional lifestyle
that an athlete needs to grow and to
develop rather than just like the actual
training session that were completing
one of the things that Reggie mentioned
to me the other day was the
professionalism that he sees when
training with you guys yeah that he
really says he struggles to see
elsewhere yeah and what I find
interesting about that you know all of
the cross hairs that are listening there
are two CrossFit's problem is there is
two things it is a training methodology
but also a competitive sport yeah and
there are some people who do it because
they like to Train CrossFit and there
are some people who train CrossFit
because they like to
p-ting CrossFit and the fact that you
have those two things running
side-by-side means that you've got the
normal class environment rock up before
Angela comes in five minutes late she'll
just jump on the c2 bike instead of
doing the wrong because everyone's
halfway around and blah blah and then
you've got the guys that want to make it
to the games want to make it to the
regional not regionals now want to make
it to the sanctioned events you know
you've got those guys who are also in
that environment you know someone who's
still maybe sweating out a couple of
beers from last night or whatever it is
and you don't have them segment it off
whereas if you look at any other sport
you have any semi-professional
professional football team they don't
also have the Sunday League team yeah
warming up with them yeah you know yeah
and it is it is two completely different
things and it'll it and it should be two
completely four things and it should
also so they've kind of so their outlook
you're looking in it probably looks
quite similar but in terms of how they
train and how they live like it it
should be a completely from I put a post
out not too long ago actually on our
Instagram about constant is just called
constantly varied or a question mark and
how on elite athletes training is rarely
constantly varied if anything it's just
constantly repeated it's just the same
is this is you get a bunch of exercises
or a bunch of workouts and there are
perfect for this tap person and it's
just repeated and repeated repeated
until the improve and then it's
developed whereas year like you say in
your CrossFit class where you've got
Angelo comes in this one I have a good
time get fit and do different movements
so it's constantly varied and it keeps
them on the toes and everyone has a good
time but to get for the elite athlete I
get so much different it's so different
is progressive overload King in all
areas yeah yeah nothing yeah only
personal you know there's other methods
but because and I would say because
CrossFit because we cover so many
different like modalities in CrossFit
running swimming or weightlifting
gymnastics we are still way behind
runners at runnin so that our training
you know our training to get better at
running needs to be so much more simple
than mo Farah's training program and our
gymnastics training is a lot more simple
to max Whitlock's training program and
the same goes for our weight liftin
wears progressive overload it can't not
work for CrossFitters because with that
I will love all these that law compared
to these elite athletes but progressive
overload for more faro probably won't
work probably not see any it'll be much
more sort of slight cyclical
periodization of ups and downs yeah that
needs to be much in much finer detail
but because we are kind of that maybe
like say we're like 70% performance then
Amin the guys were really athletes in
baseball it can be a lot more simple and
I think it's people see them the the
people are top in their sport and they
try and and copied their methods of
training but I think it's sometimes
especially for something like running
the twin is to advance that during
training sessions that is further on
them yeah certainly one of the things
that I remember seeing a few years ago
was when Megan started working with you
guys when she moved down the Wigan and
um she was talking about particular ways
of programming mana structural works or
rowing and running with splits taking a
time yeah chopping that up into
individual distances at slightly
negative splits of that yeah and then
the same for gymnastics the same again
like do you one set max and then take
the center Gees of that with no centage
rest and you know like it's the same for
everything it would appear in life
whether it be meditation whether it be
learning whether it be reading whether
it be
you know whatever your chosen domain of
competence is like pick the thing that
you can do at the maximum you can do it
for and then try and make that a little
bit more compound that a little bit more
of each time yeah and that's and that
and that in a nutshell is exactly how
are you we would period eye strain and
where there's a there's a fitness phases
of training where you do just that where
things are rolling and running this is
training separately to gymnastics and
weightlifting and then there's there's a
phase of training when you're getting
closer to competition where no we're
gonna take we're gonna take we've built
the base of all these different
modalities and we're gonna take that and
start mixing it together in some more
CrossFit or event style workout so that
you your body is fine tune in to the
stress it's gonna come up against but if
if it can handle higher rowing volume at
a higher intensity because you've you've
trained for three or four months rowing
on its own and and specifically worked
on that then when a rowing workout comes
up in an event you've got a better
foundation of Rowen to then go into
whatever it's coupled up with and if
it's coupled up with some gymnastics and
barbell if they've also been worked
separately for three or four months and
the volume and capacity of them of those
things have increased then once it all
put together you set yourself up for
better performance because you know the
base of those exercises is improving
increased massively so the limit on how
fast you can do how many reps you can do
how long you can stay on broca's
ceilings we visualize it softened and
that's how you get progression how you
progressively develop your performance
rather than a lot of people see the
competitions and they see what they get
tested on and where they fall behind on
that test and how many times you heard
someone struggling an open workout and
go I'm going to do that open workout
every week the next six months
if slam that's not just not how it works
I'm afraid it's not as simply a little
training this needs to be simple it's
not as
as simple as just doing that one workout
over and over it needs to be kind of
separated look at what energy systems
what movement mechanics go into it and
then I say build the ceiling of those
elements and then bring them together
when they need to come together when it
comes to training that's a really
important point and I've heard brought
up by Bamberger on before which is the
difference between met cons for practice
for competition and what you do in
training yeah is there a pattern at the
moment of overtraining met cons for a
lot of athletes or people starting to
catch on to the I don't know what you
call it specialization of movements yeah
I would I would hope people I think
people are catching on although it is it
is still hard for people to kind of let
go of the counter if it's like it's kind
of like a safety thing that I'm doing
Matt comms I'm getting better and you
know if I'm finishing a workout you know
completely i depleted then that's me got
better as nothing and the thing is for
the for the first fuse of CrossFit that
worked because everyone was that new to
this bar that anything would have worked
and but he's getting to that level now
where the improvements aren't as quick
in like the top tier of athletes so it
needs it needs a different approach and
it needs that I might say that special
that specialist approach way is training
things and separately and bringing them
together and actually period eyes in the
training you know with a bit more
thought than just heading train hard and
we be on the floor and then leave the
gym have you got any examples of
particular pairings that you like to put
together in terms of you know daily your
periods of pairings where you think of
someone a structural stuff with some
gymnastic stuff tends to go well or if
you're doing muscle ups with rowing I
don't know but there's some things that
you found tend to lend each other as
compliments
yes it's a you can go into you can go
into it in how much detail you want Bob
there's you've got you've got your skill
element of CrossFit so waitlisten like
math.max weight lifts now heavy weight
lifting gymnastics and the only Mac's
lifts in general and then you've got
your capacity and threshold and of
CrossFit so you know your burpees you
rowing running just the really simple
things that your assault bike simple
things that anyone can do a ball for
limited by limited by different things
you capacity is limited by if you're too
much your heart rate your threshold and
you are the skills are limited by
coordination strength balance and and
being able to used different muscle
groups from all of your bodies at the
same time kind of core contraction of
different muscle groups and
it's it's hard to it's hard to if you've
got something at this end which is like
the highest skill let's say it's let's
say your max Natchez 120 kilos if you
link that in with something capacity
based where you know your heart rate
raised then the skill breaks down and
it's not that's an obvious example like
you've used to hit max - from fresh and
completely kind of arrested and and
prepared to stay and then if you to do a
1k roller a hard intensity and then it
snapped you're not gonna you're not
going to mail it to you very unlikely to
make a lift and that's just another an
obvious example there of how a skill and
threshold how it affects each other and
then you can have it you can go into
quite a bit a detour of how you can work
them with each other so that the the
threshold of the skill and gradually
increase it over it so I see that's what
people are looking to do right in
competition yes is what I think this
seductive factor of met cons is it's the
[ __ ] I hate ninety percent of my ex
movement after I did yeah to Cairo tests
30 muscle ups for time blah blah
whatever it might be and that's where
it's like and that's that sort of send
it mentality is kinda that's what people
are chasing right it's like can I do the
thing which I could almost not do fresh
wonderful take yeah but from a training
perspective that suboptimal
it's it's not that it's suboptimal it's
the time and things like if you're gonna
have to do that at a competition then
you gotta have to get used to doing that
like when you're getting close to the
competition but long-term doing that
over and over again is not going to not
going to increase your performance
year-on-year so if it let's say it was
just rowing into some heavy snatches and
then snapped way it was under kilos and
yet imagine you will take the strength
and depth workout was double unders and
cleans and the cleans got heavier you
Toula and the heaviest weight for the
guys was 140 and the girls maybe in 93
and it's heavy
for a lot of people and that's the end
of a round about a 10-minute workout
with it probably had a good 200 or so
double unders by then and I think in
over 28 clean reps so the fatigue is
built up quite a lot there but in order
for that for that athletes performance
to increase miss a maybe you know 1200
time if that workouts to come back the
skill level of clean needs to be
increased the threshold level of working
can of those lower weight barbell
Sakhalin reps with double unders which
is now probably classes more of a lower
skill exercise building the threshold of
that building a skill level of heavy
cleans then bringing them back together
letting the body get used to that kind
of that clash of skill and threshold and
then retesting is the only way that that
type of workout it's going to improve
rather than just doing that type of
workout over and over again and I think
it is if people are clicking onto it
especially the guys that are at the top
like they they get it it's the it's the
athletes that are like wanting to get to
a sanctioning level I find that the
people gasp that compete oh good level
around love the country and they want to
get to that European all that
international level and I think it's
mainly for them where they everything
kind of guess if it makes because you
want to do so well and they want to
improve so much if you get caught into
it too much they see what other athletes
are doing a competition they want to do
that so then they do it and it's just
kind of taken that step back and having
a bit more of a sensible approach and a
logical approach um
to what can actually get them so that
season for the guys that are competing
at a local level they're not doesn't
need to be going to the games they need
to be specializing they need to be
focusing period eyes in their training
properly and not defending them
that kanji around yeah I mean it depends
on your alien age like someone everyone
everyone who starts CrossFit can just do
regular CrossFit for some maybe six
months or maybe two years and
continually get better and they probably
need to do just CrossFit for ice em we
say anyone that comes on the program
make sure you've done
CrossFit from it from a box for at least
six months of you your body is has been
exposed to CrossFit knows what it's
about and then and you also know what it
is and then start looking into maybe
like fine-tune areas but yeah anyone
that's looking to compete at any level
if you've got to a point where your
lifts have stared at a certain level you
don't feel like getting much fitter
gymnastics isn't get much better and
you're doing all those things in like
it's all muddled up in like one session
then it's time to stop separate them
work on them individually work on your
weightlifting work on you your
conditioned working in gymnastics build
them all up separately and then bring
them back together not only one it's so
simple this is that's it I've heard
Reggie Reggie always says your spew so
much logic anything I don't if you say
on your podcast me it makes me wet by
far not the worst thing that we star in
a couple weeks so I mean she should be
good mates with Reggie but yeah it seems
it does seem really really basic yeah
you know why why wouldn't you just go
away and do a microcosm of what the
specialist within each of their
disciplines are doing and then re bring
them back together
yeah um let's say that there's some
athletes listening to are those sort of
local level comps maybe scale one maybe
are X team or individual how would you
advise your athletes of that standard
how frequently would you allow them to
compete yeah this is this it's the
question everyone wants to know right
everyone wants no one everyone asks a
slice it's such a talked about thing for
our athletes on the program and just get
general in people just wanted some
advice is the always asking how often
should I compete but I think the
question might actually be how often can
can compete yeah and the answer I always
give is first of all you kneel you need
to decide why you why are you doing it
why you train and while you're competing
it are you doing it to get to the
highest physical level that you can get
your body to are you just doing it
because you enjoy competing and you
although you'd want to get a higher
level like you just like go into you
know you get although your rx comps
every few weeks and just and just doing
them and having a good time
yeah I think that's the first thing that
people need to need to understand in the
need to realize and then off the back of
that can leave em to make a decision
sorry on what on how often they compete
I would say three to four three maybe
four but definitely three competitions
per year as a maximum and try and have
them so look quite quite closely knit
sit together so there's maybe six to
eight weeks between them okay okay so I
guess fit somewhere like the UK that
works as you kind of bundle a bunch of
cops into summer yeah yeah exactly
yeah you can now also add the open prep
is probably the last comp younger or one
of the one of the last comps at the
era's apart yeah example maybe is it
also got the open now it's October and
if there's strength in depth which is
January and if there was a couple more
Abba ABBA UK or Europe based
competitions in around there then that's
kind of that your season's compete and
if your goal is for longer term
development then that gives you
potentially eight months of offseason to
do exactly what we've just been talking
about just to really break things down
and build them back up when it comes
back around to the next year's orphan
you will be in a better position to
perform better and get to a higher level
with the form higher is it's part of the
complication so one of the complications
of why people can't get better whilst
competing is that they're training in
the build-up to a cup
requires them to do more metcon style
stuff which doesn't lend itself to
improving progressively over time yeah
but how much of it is also the demands
of the comp itself is it 5050 do you
think yeah it goes it goes hand in hand
that before a competition you know the
two weeks before the volume would hoped
as dropped maybe still some intensity
there but the volume should be lower
than what it has been in the weeks
leading up so if you say there's a
two-week period there like before the
competition and then you've got a one to
two week deal or better time off after
competition then the about a month a
month where training hasn't really been
at the volume or intensity to warren
continue developing it it's been it the
volume has changed and intensity is
change so that performance for about two
days in the middle is that the best it
could be and then about two weeks is
probably nowhere near what most people
have offering anything that's in there
to recover from the stresses from that
competition yeah and and yeah then the
problem you get is people don't take the
two weeks to take two days if you look
it yeah
and then they have another one two weeks
later and it goes and just kind of like
snowball into that kind of overtraining
and I guess it's a lot of stress on the
body in a competition weekend although
or not actual the actual amount of reps
is the adrenaline the nerves CNS variety
and ass just just it's incomplete fat
mod and then just not letting it come
out of that and reset and then go back
into training that over and over again
if you compete in year round and you
compete in once a month you can just see
now how that stops someone progressing
and got a girl on the program who who
were told we basically told that whole
story to fully aware of it but she loved
competing so you know that's why she
trained so it was kind of like what
position we need to tell
like stop don't do the thing that you
like - exactly
I suppose if someone concedes the fact
that over time they're not going to
progress someone might very well be able
to say I'm fine with my lift staying the
same for the next two years and if I get
to do a competition with my friends
every two months
exactly so that again like a lot of
thing unites in principle it seems like
what we're talking about here is
understand yourself as an athlete
understand what you want from the sport
yeah and then how can you facilitate
your training and competing cadence to
allow you to enjoy that so the next
question so first off whatever we want
you to know was how often come up can I
compete the next question everyone wants
to know is how often can I do qualifies
it's a hard one now because that many of
them although the number of guys that
are in the gym they'll do class and
they'll be like oh what's going on are
you gonna do should we do some strict
presses I know I'm gonna do a qualified
deadline we've got three qualified to do
before midnight yeah it's like it's a
qualifier is competition because you
know it needs a competition maybe it's
defined that you need to be at the top
physical performance and obviously
everyone qualify if you can do a
qualifier and it was sort of similar
yeah it's same training intensity I know
a lot of volunteers like does that he'll
just do it as his train and except that
he's not going to qualify at a top mmm
but he'll qualify and you get to
competitions and in your app then you
can it'll seize the potentially lower
take in position in comp as a good
compromise yet to permit him to not to
maybe be able to train the next day
properly aw yeah exactly that's a way to
do by suppose that's relying on the fact
that you're sufficiently strong and I'm
not send it yeah and still make it yeah
you need to be already at that level to
be able to like you 90% needs to be
still everyone else is hundred
so you need to be still a good athlete
to be able to you know you that but
again he's just the qualifiers are
obviously you need to qualify to get to
a competitions we need to decide what
competition do you want to do what are
the most important competitions of the
year what I kind of like second real
that priority what I asked to that and
what further down the line and obviously
prioritize the ones that are prioritized
those qualifiers and there maybe you
have to do those qualifiers to get the
competition and just don't get sucked
into the hype of a competition you know
some really good marketing from a
competition if it's not ultimately what
you want if want you to set out to do
that yeah you're right it's very
seductive you see the you your three
friends yeah throwing down a stadium in
sunshine yeah and you like [ __ ] you know
that this sounds mint yeah but you right
you have to it's the guys saying I'm a I
know you driving with just one more pine
it's what your pine guy yeah right and
you're like [ __ ] like I really need to
consider does doing this qualifier align
with my long-term goals as an athlete
yeah yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't oh how
many people that are listening are
pushing themselves you know I love I
absolutely love the fact that the UK's
got some cool competitions you know like
but the things like the coast to coast
bike ride that we just had recently
that's that's mint
I don't worry it has a coming some of
the guys I mean probably have to take a
little bit fill the weeks are squats but
yeah you know this cool [ __ ] happening
yeah but the problem is cool [ __ ]
happening is it's distracting from
training exactly exactly and you know I
had a podcast with Eric from from we
left in 101 if you want to own me and we
went through in detail my development as
an athlete from 2010 when I started
CrossFit to to up until this point and
for the first five years the common
thing that went round and round is that
I did the open and then did regionals
and then and then it didn't compete I
mainly did that might be on one like
here and there but for five years
running it was open regionals open
region until it became open region again
and whereas now I then didn't have the
opportunity to compete every other
weekend because there wasn't a
competition to do like in 2012 there was
maybe regionals and one other UK come it
was London throw out which changed his
name about five different times but
thought what's the opportunity wasn't
that he kind of got forced just to train
properly you have to go into like an
offseason more because there's no
distractions yeah and but now like it's
the you could literally do one every
weekend which is great it's great for
the industry it's there's more people
participating in CrossFit and in
competitive CrossFit
which is brilliant but I do think it's
limiting the level of like the top level
athlete work that were producing this is
startlingly alive Reggie's an example
it's got so much Bill has got so much
potential he's 23 or 24 years old um you
know he's built like perfectly for
CrossFit and he's got a great kind of
mindset for it but he's kind of being
used to doing all these little
competitions around the country in it
and because he's done well at them like
a backspin his like it's got him gone
and he wants to keep entering and we're
actually doing about the middle ground
together in two weeks and it doesn't
know it yet and I don't know if this
will be released won't be will be after
but we're gonna finish the competition
I'm telling you that's the last time
that you do anything that's not sanction
law games and because he needs to accept
that is is better than that level of
competition not to call bath another
round or any other competitions for he
just compared at what up loser and his
beat maybe 15 games roughly in a row in
event and he's five foot four I mean
placed above Alex Smith yeah but yeah be
overall I think him 18th in the end just
came one one place above Dan Bailey yet
filthy 11550 yeah so he needs to realize
that he is he is a high-level athlete
but he needs to live and happens like a
high life like even higher vastly for
him to yeah
I mean you don't see like Dan Bailey or
Alec Smith going like oh the Cincinnati
Throwdown you're like I'm gonna go and
you know that this we're and so and I
mean they'll go to like the rogue
Invitational they'll go to the ones that
I'd erase their profile or hit their
season yeah for sure
so hey you know everything that we're
talking about here kind of it seems
comes back to firstly what your goals
and then secondly can you let your ego
and the inherent excitement of CrossFit
as a sport can you allow that to go away
from you so that you can focus on the
things yeah that matter yeah yes is the
goal that you actually like a long-term
one so that when you look back and say
you forty years old and your careers
over you can look back and say I
achieved x y&z and got to the highest
level I could physically get to rather
than having maybe been like 10% down
from that and done a lot of other no
average justjust better than average and
finishes yeah yeah because that's a
thing as well you know even if you're
not thinking about somebody that's maybe
making it to sectionals if you're in the
RX sort of division of a local comp
taking two years off to do real focused
periodized specialized work might mean
that you then come back and podium in
two years time yeah like would you
sacrifice two years of competition yeah
I've not not competing to get that I
think a lot of people probably would but
when you're in the gym and your friends
come up to you and say hey man the new
[ __ ] bout for middle ground workout
or they know this or the new that's just
been released like you are we should go
John's doing it with with them yeah but
how how know he is a decent little bit
prize wouldn't need competition so I
throw my when I tell you what it was a
good one so I went to Bali I was in Bali
when they had the isotonic drink 350 or
whatever it was called and things and
his missus won it right and they won
every single event pretty much
and then Anthony's and his missus
whether it was seven and a half grand
each
prize money it's not that's the easiest
weekend's work that anyone's done in my
life you know just I've rolled out to
Bali do a couple of workouts
[ __ ] off at 15 grand between you go
traveling for another couple of months
the ex-im deposit down on a house yeah
no you sir easy work but yeah I'm at the
mast that is the good thing about being
so I meant competitions and the
industries that it's it's becoming
easier to earn I'll make money it still
is still a hard book you know being able
to when you're Battle of Britain and get
a thousand pounds like a thousand pounds
for a lot of people who's gonna set them
up for you know it's a significant yeah
that's you that's who supplements and
you kit for a year Gela gala
I think the sponsorships men that come
off the back of it again yeah for sure
um it's is a it's an interesting one man
another thing to consider as well if you
you know an athlete that's listening is
think about the fact that there are more
competitions and that more people are
getting into doing them everybody else
is coming up against the same challenge
that you are at the moment which is that
competing is seductive and it seems cool
and there's more CrossFit gyms and more
CrossFit members and blah blah blah that
means that if you can do something which
gives you a competitive advantage which
includes not competing if you can do the
thing that no one else is doing and you
know you can see on the walls four
people are just listening wearing steez
garage gym and I'm surrounded by shirts
and and memorabilia from all manner of
top level competitions you can see that
the people whom for them the top level
of the sport is the goal that is what
they're doing they're not allowing their
athletes to compete all of the time if
you want to do that if you want to move
the needle in that direction then
presumably you have to take on board
some of those principles yeah yeah
understand and I always matter for the
feelings that athletes have at the end
of a competition when they see the
leaderboard you see where they've
finished and maybe they're not so
satisfied by it they want to place
higher next
just at that moment those feelings that
have those like raw emotions that you
have there at the end of a competition
is remember those emotions and then and
then planet if it's that same
competition in 12 months later it spun
back from there and how do you get from
that that position that you're in right
now to having the emotions that you want
want to happen and does that include
competing every every month or every two
you want does it meaning like not going
down and if you think if the if the 10
competitors they attempt and the 10
competitors at both yeow and Nan above
you are gonna compete three or four
times then that's like we said before if
it's a month out you're training for
every competition now four months
potentially that there that you could
gain on them if you're just doing a
little bit this this of you're off
training on your lifestyle you are
recovery your nutrition that's going to
help you improve that a little bit more
if that's a little bit more than you're
the person that just beat you then in 12
months time that a little bit more all
that inch what I say inches to yards to
miles yeah is it's gonna put you in a
key it's your competitive advantage
right that is your competitive advantage
the drain the difference in your
modality the difference in the cadence
of you competing that is it so I think I
hope that it's given some people sort of
a second thought about whether or not
they're competing schedule is
facilitating their goals in training
yeah I was listening to something on the
way down here about evolutionary
psychology about how the anticipation of
an event is often the pleasure derived
from the anticipation of an event is
often so much higher than the event
itself or the aftermath yeah
it's why thinking about eating food is
often actually better than the food or
the example that was used was um you you
think about a holiday you book a holiday
six months in advance you get excited
for six months in fact it's gonna be
amazing
I'm gonna go with this beach and there's
gonna be a sunset and you're looking at
all the Instagram photos of it then you
get to the beach and you sit down yeah
well this is nice there's a bit Sun
between my toes you know might be it
could be a bit colder and blah blah blah
yeah but when you look back you don't
remember the Sun
and when you anticipate you don't think
about it yeah so what you actually want
to do and you can hack your way and
Happiness by by doing this is plan the
things that you want to do well in
advance because you essentially get to
enjoy the event and some of them and sit
at the tree kind of dopamine kicks that
you get so plan right I am going to do
strength and depth
20:21 yeah I knew that right that's my
goal I get to think about that event for
all of this time you know yeah and that
right that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
do it this is when the qualifiers are
gonna come out and I'll plan towards
that as opposed to just being ragged
around by all this event that I've never
heard of but happens to be within 50
miles of me has really some online
qualifiers should we go bin ourselves
tomorrow yeah yeah and and you know what
the thing is it's it's it's hard to
commit it it's hard to commit to
training for eight months and not being
that that position in in the competition
and testing yourself like the day-to-day
lifestyle and commitment to training can
get a bit monotonous and it can be can
be hard but you just have to keep the
kind of end goal kind of clearing your
head though of what you are working
towards and I think that's why people do
then just go to and do a competition
because they need that kind of kick and
go and keep the motivation high ball if
you can kind of just clearly set the
path from now until the competition in
eight to eight to twelve much time and
just keep chipping away and just go that
month by month rather than just thinking
oh it's gonna be eight months until I
compete again and just kind of break it
down then you probably steer away from
you know being kind of sucked in to
compete in every month I guess having a
training partner or like a little squad
of people that are potentially on that
more I don't want to call it more
virtuous journey that more long-term
gold bounce off each other you think
that might be a good way to kind of yeah
take that more robust and that's that's
probably another thing that we've
created there in jxt we've got a group
of guys that understand it so they're
not kind of like they're not kind of
force each of his swan goes into the
competition that was wasn't kind of
plumbing that he just came out of the
blue then it's kind of all why are you
doing that we've got you supposed to be
focusing on role can you
coming up in May awesome tuna yeah if
you have that group that kind of all
aligned in the same kind of mentality of
of train and then it definitely makes
can't go to each other here this
decisions a lot easier one thing that I
wanted to bring up you mentioned about
the CNS frying nature of doing
competitions talk to me about why it's
like taking jst your business your Jim
over to the games as the first British
team and then talk to me about the
aftermath that what was you CNS like
before during and after yeah so I mean I
think the the most I've struggled is
2015 games didn't really have much
that's what I think the jst computer
always thought it was around then it was
there was probably 10% of the amount of
people on it as there is now but it was
still there it was still it was still a
thing and that was probably the only
thing as well as in the gym that I had
outside training so training was just
like you were you're not raising you had
training people to train in had trained
a huge great online yeah exactly yeah
but my own train itself like my wife
Italian and my friends around me was
like if if anything didn't help me with
training then there was a hindrance a
privilege
yeah it was kind of out the way and that
for years and years and end and then
having the competition and it being a
bit of a brutal competition 2015 games
so then coming back to it all just kind
of like uh it's like happened and then
you see and I still haven't my laughs
teeth like that was really struck up I
had ton three weeks rest after
competition shot the three weeks rest
came back to trainer for a week and then
need another six I've been just I don't
know every was münster because for so
long in my head like it would build or
not to get again five years or so and
then like it kind of I was in LA for
like four weeks on Hamas and Muscle
Beach competing in front of thousands
and then and then I get back into my
front room in Wigan in its mid dogs
might up to go for a walk in its base
and
oh so that kind of whole like dump of
adrenaline and lying expectations then
the flight back to normal normality um I
think I think it's that that people
struggle with when you're out
competition you names being called out
on from the embassy in the crowd cheer
you know and then you have a good event
and it's the dolphins are flying like
you go from that and then it suddenly
being like over and like two days later
you're back home and like [ __ ] where do
you go yeah it's like that I think
that's what athletes do with the mast as
opposed to maybe the actual physical
effects of the competition is that dump
but having having experienced that quite
badly in 2015 like I'm able to know I
know it's gonna happen now I know I did
what a pleasure the weekend the know to
have a great time and I'm gonna come
home and I got exit because he expected
how would feel like if you learned later
than I experience 2015 am so getting
that across to the guys as well as it's
quite important for them to then regain
motivation and have about rather than
that hitting them like a bottom being my
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah so I feel
like that's in terms of call it CNS but
in terms of just kind of having like
that and that don't after competition
it's more than just CNS right it's like
you will be fatigued from the level of
work that you've put in but it's like a
socio-cultural
thing as well that's been going on I
have been placed in high esteem
here is egos just game yeah hole
shoveled into it like that yeah sure I
know I recently did a podcast have done
too with DJ's recently guy called
Christoph and another one called Danny T
and I'm both of those guys talk about
their post show slump and Danny deals
with it a lot better than thing Christos
but he's supporting Eric Prydz around
the world he's playing to thousands of
people he's literally living
for this guy and he gets back to the
hotel and it's just him and a room
service and a flight in four hours time
to go to Buenos Aires or where I was
next on the tour and it's just lonely
and sad man and you know you see this
with people like Avicii Tim Berg you
know a DJ who had the capability had the
artistic capacity but he wasn't able to
deal with the socio-cultural egos side
that exposure that stuff and people
don't see athletes in that same light
right they don't view them as performers
despite the fact that you have to
perform like it's in you know you're
paying to watch it yes it is a
performance you know yeah a hundred
percent and I guess it's the same for
every every sports class where you see
footballs and rugby players
I haven't know having a tough time when
they've retired because they've gone
from a living that life to then retired
and then BOOM
but it's a CES was kind of that on a
different scale I guess so you found
that 2015-2017 you got to be thinking
right I need to prepare myself a little
bit more gently somehow or account for
it when I come back and then 19 as well
what was some of the strategies that you
put in place to kind of bring yourself
out of that slump yeah I think it just
helps knowing that that's a thing and it
happened and it happens I could just
show you out you if you if you're
prepared for it I wasn't prepared for
after the episode 15 no one warned you
there was gonna carry on going and then
it is fisted by something but thanks
pianist so just simply just being aware
that it happens and it's normal because
you go from having oars and dolphins and
having the greatest time your life to
then just being back to you to you
normal life yeah just understanding that
that happens just helps right greatly
but also for me just like not making
immediate plans like after the game so
people always say how are you gonna
another comeback
retired for time yeah as though it's not
it's not I'm having a comeback or
retiring it's them just taking more time
off and then only restarting when I know
about I'm ready to build back up drain
and compete again if I was someone if I
tried competing through your 2018-19 and
continued then I probably wouldn't be
able to compete any market what I
wouldn't be good enough or it I've just
lost or for it so just not kind of bacon
immediate plans when the main
competition whether it's games or its
you know I'd really ill or what have you
doing not having immediate plans for
that two weeks after to do another
competition another competition it just
accepting just to come out of that that
step that step down a step away let you
in mind and your body just completely
reset and then get back into it when you
ready to get back into it you don't know
where your heads gonna be you know I
mean sometimes the it's an it's a
great-sized that you'll two weeks after
training you're you're flying in the end
you can't wait to get back yes oh yes
yeah best-case scenario it's a great
indicator that your body's in a good
place you mines in a good place but a
lot of people then just ran they don't
have that feeling they try and like
maybe you have that maybe start
officially make that feeling and that's
when it just kind of like gets a little
bit out of control so yeah like in 2017
and so that was in nineteen just I just
kind of accepted that I didn't need to
train you know I trained when I wanted
to and then enjoy that made me enjoy it
because I wanted to do it and because
there's a lot of times as an athlete
where you have to do a lot from training
sessions and a lot of things that every
part of you does not want to do it my
keys it goes butts they're constantly a
very poor said that it's not always a
fun thing to do is trillion like sitting
on a roller and doing 12500 me at rolls
with a miniature asters unless you love
rowing like I don't love row anything
off no I said no one loves really
oh hi so a lot of those little facts
that you have in your head
like to do this thing that you don't
want to do over and over again for years
and years like just to be able to then
have a moment of time where holy let go
I don't have to do it anymore it's just
it's like such a nice feeling and then
if you gradually find yourself being
like to get by man I miss that yeah well
it's the same as you know the first bite
of ice cream is real tasty but if I make
you eat five legalized everything that
by the end of it it's not that good yeah
there's a quote from James clears atomic
habits where he spoke to a Chinese
weightlifting coach and he said what
separates the very very best lifters
from everybody else and he says it's the
lifters who can put up with boredom the
most yeah you know I think there is a
young kind of like this folklore belief
that guys at the top end of the sport
somehow have like a bottomless pit of
motivation it's like it's not it's got
nothing to do with that as far as I can
see not in any way being it believed
that laughing but it appears to be who
can withstand the monotony and the
boredom yeah better than everybody else
yeah and a final point there on what you
just said is when you take a love and
turn into a labor it can sometimes
overshoot being a labor of love and just
become work yeah you know like if
training is your job but you trained
because you loved it and now you train
because you what you have to do you know
like everyone sees the punch-drunk forty
five-year-old heavyweight boxer coming
back for one more fight because you know
and it looks sad but there's an
equivalent of people doing that to
themselves mentally yeah in the gym yeah
no you passed your passion your passion
has left you behind and you're now like
just ringing out every last drop of
willpower that you've got to get
yourself through a training session
yeah which Taz Nadine just feels like
play to him Alford Zac George just feels
like you know because everything's brand
new because he's 12
yeah like yeah you know an absolute
monster he's actually going against as
sure as well this is over yeah
unbelievable man oh yeah like like Tyson
Fury is an example that I'm sure he had
retired and then he'd hit a stage where
he in I think that recently there was a
madama someone's game swimming his horse
show about a lot the depression it had
gone through and like and but he had
that premiered a couple of years off and
he's was he just beat now dealt a while
there anything back to being world
champion yeah is just a perfect example
there is that there needs to be a bit of
a reset to be able to account for
longevity and compete I wonder I wonder
how many athletes that will never we'll
never know but there are at the top end
of the sport you know wonder how much
better know we're also know Matt Fraser
our Pat valanor or Bradford Kowski or
you know like ta Claire to me or
whatever I wonder how many of those
could be even better
you know if they took a year yes a
regain cuz you don't know no one's ever
this is the sort of thing that no one
will ever put in an Instagram post where
they'll say do you know what it is my
desire to Train actually is waning at
the moment and I don't love the sport
but I've maybe still got five years of
career in me yeah you know like it's a
real onion spoken about mechanism that's
happening yeah that was one who sent me
in 2016 so for after hey slump yeah he's
just like in the head everyone's gonna
get back to the games yeah Prussia drank
about the games this is just a collapse
what I've been doing for last few years
should do it again and like I wouldn't a
binge having struggled to kind of like
get the drive to get back trade and
after after the games just kind of like
forced myself into it and just getting
back into that routine again and then
just applying everything just as much
they did in 2015 in 2016 and then
actually got injured in regionals on the
second event a thousand sixteen it was
at that point when I got injured
although I was gutted to be injured and
I really didn't want to be like it was
such a relief to have gotten injured and
looking back now if I had taken out if
after 2015
if I'd listened to that part of my head
that was saying shouldn't compete this
year I should just tear this year off
improve and get yourself to be a top ten
games individual in 2017 because she
need that town like there's part of my
head that was saying that and then you
got the other part the head it was
saying get last the games actually and
then do the year after then you have to
be a five times Games athlete yeah and
if I look back now the nah I would I
wouldn't have competing 2016 and I saved
it mm what 2017 the the other side of
that is that we went then I then
competed in an amazing team of all the
great people became the first team to
call if a thing ends with 717 so if I
was thinking soul is of an individual
then I would've competed so I'm 16 and
would hopefully been in that position
positions on 17 but then say what about
that you might not have ended up here so
everything I love is so long yeah I you
know I wouldn't know how we can focus on
our better nature
so to speak I don't really know the
thing is well is it's beautiful with
hindsight to say well yeah like of
course I should have taken a break now
in 2015 but if you've not got engine
you'd walked into another game spot yeah
you'd have been like yeah I knew a new
diagram you threw out yeah exactly so I
want to finish on this itrex it's
something that keeps coming up in
discussions that I have with people and
it's how do you know when enough is
enough
within training you know jst I think
especially with the this new wave of
athletes that you've got that are coming
through they the guys train hard you
know they do like to go hard how do you
know when it's time to slow down because
you're pushing your body too much and
how do you know when you need to push
more because you've got that some left
in the tank yeah I mean it's hard to
it's hard to just kind of like say a few
things like I say I just inside me just
like know when it's time to take some
time off um I know my art for my own
performance and for my own thing on my
own life that if relationships are
business
having a negative effect on my own
health
like in last year a local piece at the
games I had a kidney infection of chest
infection and an ear infection that's
where they live for months and that was
between having qualified at rec Ubik and
then before the games so for me during
that time that was like wrong this is
enough indication
I've got those those infections that
life was busy I was six six months or so
old at that point like this is too much
that's compete like that are X plus plus
place yeah so competing and training to
be an athlete after think once I'll get
through to this game that once that's
done it just needs to take a back burner
and so I feel like I'm ready to go again
and it took for all it took I'm August
and then December it was like right okay
I feel like I've got everything to
control my health better I mean a better
routine with the baby and the business
in is a is a better position for me to
be able to bring training back into and
I forget my I was always training but
bring live classes proper training yeah
so I guess it's she's got a before
anyone else they've just got to
understand like the priorities in the
laughs and oh they having a negative
effects from training and issue
performance also not benefiting from
constantly going and going isn't it
interesting that he was saying in 2015
anything that was in your life that
didn't serve you was pushed to the side
because of training yeah and then move
it forward so 2017 2019 and you're using
those the quality of those other things
in your life as the canary in the coal
mine to tell you when trainings going
too far in this sort of strangely
poetically ironic how that comes back
around yeah and I guess probably just
answer other I've got older there's been
a shift in priorities because business
and families as has come to the top of
the lesson naturally and is now on what
number three so I guess tre
is the hindrance sometimes to a family
in business yeah it's kind of turned on
its head
okay I said that for the next year or so
awful lot of competitions I've got
planned I'm enjoying the fact that it is
turned on its head and I'm still able to
perform at a decent level and just see
where it kind of gets me to with a bit
of a different perspective I think
certainly you know watching people like
kara Webb
what's a nuna Saunders Kara Saunders
sorry Kara you know watching her
watching an athlete choose to be a mom
in the like slap-bang in the middle of a
career that to second place finishes in
a row or something then kid like the
strength of will that it takes to decide
to put your athletic career to the side
and maybe the fear is never come back
you know I'm sure that she well she's a
monster but like you know to see people
do that I think it's I think it's very
very healthy to see people you know
having the wholesome family life yeah
because the bottom line is that for
pretty much everyone the family the
child's life everything that is what
he's going to be the most important
thing but the immediate gratification of
no but one more year competing one more
year training you know you can one more
Europe until you're so it's so late that
you may be climbing and that's real big
sacrifice to make yeah yeah and it just
shows that you know deep down and if
we're using Kara as as the example that
she her long to like life goals that may
be in line that involves kids more so as
she's not many people can say they've
come second at the games you know twice
or no you know she's probably in a
full-time salary from being an athlete
so she's kind of ticks those boxes but
there's only so long in her life that
she's gonna be able to take their start
a family box uh-huh and she knows that
knocking she's proven now that she'll
always be able to return to the athlete
it's always a bit of a nor knows where
this you're you'll always be women got
through quite a lot in there
pregnancy soared geniuses or monster
chambers and body make changes and
everything so being able to get back to
that level is always a bit of a gamble
maybe but I mean she's proving that
she's uh she's what she was competing
actually this weekend in Australia where
I think they're shooting in the Austria
how cool is it gonna be if she makes it
back to the game like if she if she
steps back did she not do it from the
I'm not sure I don't know but yeah I
think you know to kind of round up what
we've gone through there there's
certainly a unifying principle across
everything it would seem which is what
are your goals with in training with in
life you know with in work with in
business all the rest of it and are the
things that you're doing on a daily
basis moving you toward that and then on
top of that like okay I know I need to
do my training needs to look like this
and then how can I ensure that all of
the individual parts the tiny inches how
can those add up towards yards and miles
yeah and as long as you're consistently
reflecting and moving back toward it
yeah well you know it may it makes it
seem really [ __ ] simple yeah the game
so people want to find out about GST
where do they go
yeah so Instagram where app jst
underscore compete that's where most I
hope that's my most our information is
BST compete calm yeah was the two main
main pages and then at all our actual
programming is on fitter trading at
website which all ill directly to after
then you just take a look through and
she was an email or an Instagram message
and beautiful matte people hadn't come
down to Sonya weekend coming the other
companies woman getting my little wah
we've got six people in any box six here
um everything that we've spoken about
will be linked in these show notes below
statement vanoss I really appreciate you
tanks Ron thank you bro Julia thank you
[Music]
you